before the movie begins a prologue is
shown highlighting that over 40 percent
of the global population experiences
sleep paralysis the terrifying thing is
that the majority of these people have
experienced being attacked by demonic
entities in the opening scene we see a
young girl named Sophie who is awakened
by a screaming voice of her mother
Helena she cautiously makes her way to
her parents room but suddenly her mom
comes out and hugs her she tells Sophie
to not look inside however the kid
mistakenly looks inside only to be
startled by the horrific sight of her
father's death in the next scene we are
introduced to a criminal psychologist
named Kate Fuller who wakes up at her
apartment and starts her daily routine
shortly after he receives a call from a
detective named McCarthy who summons her
to Helena's residence upon arriving
detective McCarthy informs her that
Helena murdered her husband he asks Kate
to deduce whether or not she should be
committed to a mental institution
Cadence firstly shown the lifeless body
of Helena's husband whose eyes have
turned red and his body is Twisted in an
unusual manner following this Kate goes
to interview Sophie who is hiding under
the bed in her grandfather's room in
hopes of gathering information about the
incident Kate crawls under the bed and
somehow convinces the kid to talk Sophie
tells her that the one who killed her
father is
confused Kate then goes to Helena to ask
about Mara but the latter screams in
Terror as she hears the name afterwards
Helena is brought to the police station
for questioning she reveals that her
husband was having an affair and this
led to a major crack in their marriage
however Helena promises that she didn't
kill her husband according to her on
that fateful night she suffered from
sleep paralysis when she sensed an evil
presence in the room before long Mara a
sleep demon climbed into her husband's
chest and killed him hearing all this
detective McCarthy believes that Helena
is mentally unstable so he advocates for
her transfer to a mental institution
when Kate doesn't find any evidence
regarding the Murder She also signs the
papers to send Helena to the mental
hospital shortly after Helena is allowed
to see her daughter one last time but
they are soon separated by the officials
later as the clock strikes midnight Kate
experiences a bout of sleep paralysis
during which she Witnesses a strange fig
gear in her kitchen she soon becomes
normal when the figure walks away after
this she is unable to sleep so she
starts going through the evidence she
collected from Helena's house a note
captures her attention which has a
message that says Takahashi knows
everything the following day she drives
to takahashi's has to talk about the
incident however she instead finds his
decayed corpse killed in the same manner
as Helena's husband this prompts her to
summon detective McCarthy who believes
that Helena killed both of them Kate
tries to convince him to investigate in
more depth but the detective tells her
not to interfere in his work undeterred
Kate proceeds to the mental institution
to talk with Helena she asks her about
Takahashi and a man named Dougie whom
her father claimed to be the killer
Helena then shares her husband's story
saying that he had a sleep problem so
they went to a sleep paralysis support
group run by Dr Ellis it's the same
place where they met Takahashi and
Dougie in addition Helena shows her a
red mark on her left eye claiming that
marks her victims and that she's coming
for her as well she begs Kate to let her
see her daughter one last time or else
she'll die here alone after hearing all
of this Kate decides to attend the sleep
paralysis support group where she meets
several people suffering from sleeping
problems including Dougie during the
session everyone shares that they see a
demonic entity while they suffer from
sleep paralysis one guy though says that
he sees leprechauns Dougie then abruptly
gets up and insists that Mara is real he
also suggests everyone not sleep or else
they'll be killed too Dr Alice dismisses
these claims as hallucinations but
Dougie points out one of the group
members with glasses named Saul claiming
that he will die tonight furthermore he
also takes off Saul's glasses revealing
that his eyes have turned completely red
a sign that Mara is around him following
the group's session Kate goes to
detective McCarthy to share Dougie's
claims about Saul's impending demise
however the detective shrugs off her
concerns like the detective he is
and walks away this frustrates Kate and
she eventually decides to call it a day
upon arriving home she plays her
voicemails and hears a message from
Helena pleading for assistance as Mara
is coming for her in an attempt to calm
herself Kate pours a drink and
eventually falls asleep on her couch
unfortunately just a few seconds later
she awakens in a state of sleep
paralysis and again encounters the same
figure oh God beneath her table she
suddenly gets up as the figure vanishes
meanwhile Saul gets so scared by The
Entity that he commits The Unthinkable
by immolating himself in front of the
church not long after detective McCarthy
along with his team arrives at the scene
he then recalls Kate's story about how
dougie predicted the death alarmed he
quickly reaches out to Kate and they
apprehend Dougie on the grounds a
frightening Saul to death that's right
he was so scared he lit himself on fire
doggy doesn't reveal anything until Kate
asks him about Mara he discloses The
Takahashi her the first time he also
didn't believe in this but now he does
according to Dougie Mara has been
killing people for a long long time he
then shows a red mark in his eyes and
says that one can't sleep after they are
marked the detective still doesn't
believe his words but they are forced to
let him go as they have no evidence
against him after this interrogation
detective McCarthy opts to release
Helena because Dougie is now their Prime
Suspect with this good news Kate drives
to the mental institution to pick up
Helena only to find her dead in the same
manner as her husband this devastates
her and she starts blaming herself for
the poor woman's demise in the aftermath
Kate seeks solace in her home's bathtub
trying to relax herself minutes later
she falls asleep and soon awakens in a
state of sleep paralysis this is when
she is confronted by Mara Jesus from
behind the curtain moments later the
figure disappears causing her to regain
her Mobility Kate then finds foot marks
on the floor making her realize that
Mara is of hallucination but reality
unless she's hallucinating the
footprints too to make matters worse she
also finds a red mark in her eye
indicating that she is the next Target
the next day Kate sneaks into detective
McCarthy's office and watches the video
footage of Helena's death in the mental
institution in this footage she
discovers a dark shadow-like figure on
top of Helena strangling her to death in
order to learn more about this Kate
visits Dougie whose left eye is now
turned completely red she learns that
Dougie has been doing tons of research
in order to find the link between Mara
and her victims and the reason why she's
killing them he explains Mara's history
and her recorded deaths and that her
cycle begins following a tragedy
according to Dougie's findings Mara
appears in stages firstly a person is
paralyzed and they see her secondly Mara
marks the person thirdly the person
comes into physical contact and in the
final stage the person can see Mara even
when he or she is awake but if they fall
asleep sleep they will die Dougie also
claims that marrow only appears when
someone is in a deep sleep as a result
of this he only takes power naps setting
alarms in 20-minute intervals and
turning on blaring music in order to
keep him awake unable to digest this
information Kate goes to talk with Dr
Ellison shows him the video footage of
Helena unfortunately the doctor doesn't
believe in Mara and attributes sleep
paralysis as a manifestation of one's
cultural influence Dr Ellis what the
does that mean that very night Kate is
fast asleep but she is roused by a
strange sound she wakes up and is
startled by the vision of Helena who
tells her that she left her alone to die
despite the initial fright Kate regains
her composure and settles back into
sleep at the stroke of midnight she
awakens and experiences sleep paralysis
once more this time she sees Mara who
sits on her chest and places hands
around her neck moments later the figure
disappears prompting Kate to get up and
choke on the other hand Dougie's
generator dies stopping his alarm clocks
and making him sleep more than the
safety limit he suddenly wakes up and
freaks out believing that he has now
entered the final stage driven by fear
of imminent death he quickly calls Kate
seeking her help to save him now that he
is afraid to fall asleep Dougie resorts
to Extreme Measures attempting to cut
off his eyelids goddamn doggy but
fortunately Kate arrives just in time
and takes him to Dr Ellis there he is
placed under close observation in a
controlled environment Dr Ellis assures
him that he can sleep as much as he
wants if any anomalies arise he promises
to wake Dougie up before falling asleep
though Dougie shares his guilt from the
past from when he accidentally killed
innocent people during the war the damn
Dougie as Dougie falls asleep Kate sits
on a nearby couch while Dr Ellis and her
co-worker are at the control room
vigilantly monitoring Dougie's condition
and his cultural influence as midnight
Falls Dr Alice and her co-worker get
distracted and at this very time
shows up Kate awakens but gets stuck due
to sleep paralysis in this state she
Witnesses Mara who advances towards
Dougie and starts twisting his neck this
suddenly catches Dr Ellis's attention
propelling him to rush towards Dougie
however he is unable to understand
what's happening and before he can do
anything Dougie dies after this Mara
moves towards Kate but Dr Ellis manages
to wake her up just in time preventing
her death however now Kate's eyes have
turned even more red implying that she
has entered the third stage yep she's
friggin baked later as the cops are
investigating the scene detective
McCarthy receives a call informing him
that Sophie has been admitted to the
hospital when Kate learns this she
rushes to the hospital where she
discovers that the kid has also Fallen
prey to Mara's grip and is already in
the final stage Kate then requests
Sophie's grandfather keep her awake but
her words fall on deaf ears because the
grandfather is deaf and she's asked to
leave in the next scene a determined k 8
returns to Dougie's Shack and makes a
graph of all the victims attempting to
put together the link between them after
finding Dougie's War memorabilia she
begins to put the pieces together
Douglas felt guilty for killing innocent
people during the war Saul was shattered
after accidentally causing his mother's
death Holly and his Husband felt guilty
for having an affair Helena blamed
herself for their impending divorce and
Kate blamed herself for Helena's death
Kate then calls detective McCarthy to
know about Takahashi the latter reveals
that Takahashi was a chef at a primary
school one day he prepared contaminated
fish which accidentally caused the
deaths of 38 innocent kids Jesus
Takahashi probably should have gotten
the chair after hearing this Kate learns
that Mara targets people who are
overcome with guilt over things they've
done which means the entire world is
screwed the detectives still hesitate to
believe her and ask her about Sophie's
guilt in response Kate tells them that
the kid blames herself for talking to
her and sending her mother to the mental
Assad with this newfound information
Kate decides to head back to the
hospital to rescue Sophie on her way she
has multiple haunting visions of Helena
and Mara which causes her to meet with
an accident despite this setback Kate
continues her way to the hospital
unfortunately she falls asleep and
enters the fourth stage with both of her
eyes turning completely red Kate begins
to see the deadly visions of Mara but
she somehow manages to reach the
hospital once there Kate finds Sophie in
a state of sleep paralysis and attempts
to wake her up just then Mara shows up
so Kate hugs Sophie courageously
admitting that she is the one who is
guilty not the kid miraculously Mara
vanishes and the redness Fades away from
Sophie's eyes having ensured the safety
of the child Kate's exhaustion overcomes
her causing her to fall asleep shortly
after she awakens to a spectral vision
of Helena who continues to blame Kate
for her demise unable to let go of her
guilt Kate suffers from sleep paralysis
and the movie ends with Mara lunch
toward her subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching